[Applause]
we know
Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world and this
will be a change that the world has long
needed
[Music]
the United Kingdom is marching with us
towards the most I think the most
important victory of our lifetime it
will be a victory over the very idea of
the war
after we went together any aggressor it
doesn't matter big or small will know
what awaits him if he attacks
International order
any aggressor
any aggressor who will try to push the
bandaris by force who will inflict
destruction and Death on other peoples
who will try to endure his dictatorship
at the ex at the expense of other
people's blood in criminal and
unprovoked Wars as the Kremlin does any
aggressor is going to lose
ladies and gentlemen we have already
achieved remarkable results and we must
make every effort to turn our
achievements into the foundations of the
future Global Security
architecture the world the world needs
your leadership Britain just as it needs
Ukrainian bravery